hey guys I'm Ryan right this is when you
say your name oh [ __ ] me yeah
I'm Justin Ullman Justin Melvin Justin's
a friend of mine he is cool he is not in
the movie business but he is a gamer so
I still want to bring my buddy by to
check out the trailer for destiny cuz I
know so much about this game so much
it's so good it's it's you know bungees
first game after their departure for
Microsoft Studios right game studios the
way it looks I didn't see any of the
stuff yet hence the reason we're here
but it looks like it's gonna be all the
goodness of Halo first-person shooter
but in a massively multiplayer online
environment uh-huh so picture like with
as many people as Warcraft all playing
Halo all at the same time running
missions all over the place dude that is
like that's gonna give a Nana sandwich
for sure that's gonna be awesome
Wow I've never actually played World of
Warcraft I know how it works that would
be yeah that sounds [ __ ] insane
actually yeah I mean a halo be Jesus
guys game you could have in Halo like
proper back in the day was like eight
people mm-hmm and they're just like well
we tried 10,000 yeah sort of eight about
ten thousands like vehicles and
everything okay cool cool well exactly
this trailer
it's called destiny now that there are
two trailers I could sometimes assume
you guys get really pissed off and we
watch it other two trailers out one said
it came out a year ago and this one said
I came out three weeks ago so we're
going when they came out three weeks ago
okay yeah if it's wrong I'm sorry was
the e3 spot so like just a couple of
weeks ago yeah okay perfect
let's check it out
we called it the trap and its arrival
changed us forever great cities will put
on Mars and Venus mercury became a
garden world human lifespan tripled oh
it was a time of miracles we stared out
at the galaxy and knew that it was our
destiny to walk in the light of other
stars but the traveler had an enemy Oh a
darkness which had hunted it for eons
across black gulfs of space but like
that centuries after our Golden Age
began this darkness found us and that
was the end of everything
whoa that is until I found you
Oh
Wow do you do they look beautiful slow
really snowed the darkness would return
to finish what it started
do take our home
that's why I've been looking for
for centuries there are only a few of
you who carry the light of the traveler
who have the strength to fight the
darkness
I'm not going to lies you Guardian you
are Earth's last hope
does he make it
Star Wars
everything you know
everything humans have ever do it's like
a war game it's awesome man
gone forever
so you know
no pressure
become legend product not yet rated I
love to become legend yeah it's your
name legend legendary yeah that's my
full name
legendary it's longer how ironic
okay yeah that game does look cool it
looks
I love the whole vibe of it all going on
yeah like that epic war vibe that is so
cool to me that it's like you know like
a lot of games will take place like oh
there's a war going on battlefield and
[ __ ] but this one really if it I feel
the grand scope of it all it's like
watching an epic film yeah I didn't get
that it was massively multiplier in
there that's just what I heard so in
comments if you could let me know
whether or not I'm full of it oh I'd be
great yeah they will they will it'll be
yeah it'll be F it'll be my destiny that
guy doesn't know [ __ ]
Oh mo but yeah I mean that's how I heard
was like massively multiplayer
first-person shooter let's see if you
heard correctly I don't know if that was
game foot you think it was game footage
or just like footage for cinematic
gameplay cinematic footage um yeah might
have been cinematic it looked like it
cut back and forth between the two yeah
I'm not entirely sure know these days
though you know chef Ilan said sometimes
you can tell different times yeah
zoom sounds aside whoa look how good
these perfect sounds you like a fresh
from Drella prom it all feels good and
you're just trying to roll with it even
I a little uncomfortable I've said some
pretty awful things in my life for some
reason what you said I don't know that
game totally looks like it's gonna be
worth my money where I'm gonna go broke
just because I couldn't wait a little
while longer to play a game cuz I wanted
to keep up with the cool crowd yeah
pressure in society launch day at
midnight lying outside of Game Stop I'll
be there oh yeah I'm gonna order it on
Amazon just wait for it to come out door
anyway guys if you're new to the channel
you can click this link right here to
subscribe and I just did a video come
with a damn Justin
how'd you who's dead who's Dan Justin
has he's co-creator coca-cola foundry
found out Justin is co-founder of that
new app called slinger that's SL ing r
mm-hmm because they are illiterate and
that is why they spelled it that way
yeah if I remember the explanation mean
that correct he looks weird type it
looks weird is that the only actual
reason you guys cuz it's slinger with
just the R because it looked weird
it definitely has nothing to do with
domain name registration at all so
there's like no actual like
philosophical meaning or something
behind the title okay okay it's a cool
app though it's cool that it helps you
get laid I'll tell you that much we try
our best yeah any a lot of you guys
asked me for advice because you're under
this impression I'm having sex with a
lot of girls which is so true every girl
that comes on this channel I have sex
with if any of them deny it they are
[ __ ] liars and [ __ ] oh I told you
forgot hahaha subscriber shoutout time
Leo Pelle
he said you're so [ __ ] funny you make
my day can you please give me a
shout-out yes I can leo Pelle BAM
Leonardo de Pelle Wow I [ __ ] love you
man
you deserve this shout-out cuz you
complimented me anyone who gives me a
compliment deserves a shout-out so I
would like as many compliments as
possible I want to give millions of
shoutouts one day that would take a long
time yeah you'd be dead before you get
to the end of it would be dead yeah
would you do this to me leo
oh sorry forgot we're going over his
eyes I'm the knight can i have a shout
out please you guys is the epic stuff of
uh I don't know yeah you're awesome well
my friend I feel like with the way you
phrase your words you could have been
one of the people who helped contribute
to the title of the slinger rap you or
something my friend like every like
flicker
did you bang the Flickr guys like that
no no oh then come on do you say did I
bang the flicker card guys like that
about the e there's no Ian flicker
either oh like a million billion you
know 500 million users well you know I'm
sure there was a you know a better
explanation as to opposed it looks weird
it's definitely not a domain name I hope
you're not lying about it I'm the knight
okay first off Batman if you're gonna
you know be Batman you gotta learn how
to spell a little better gotta
communicate better
can you imagine Batman stuttering where
is it [ __ ] yeah Joe Joker name I mean
Bane [ __ ] the bad guy no I love you uh I
hate anyhow shoutouts August you are
they gonna get made fun of we're getting
it an awesome compliment don't know why
it's one of the two extremes but I'm
gonna make sure to mention that I do
love you Nick Diaz I don't know if he
meant to put give a shout out but he
said I just want to give a shout out to
the most funniest guy for making making
the best reactions of one of my new
favorite upcoming movies 22 Jump Street
wow I am so behind on these Janet's and
get a number for the hot emic hot pocket
with a little bit of hot sauce on the
top what are you talking about my friend
you want to give me a shout-out we'll
look what's happening look what's
happening what's going on what's going
on
Ryan's giving you a shout-out right now
in your face I beat you to it or is that
your shout out the comic in that case
the fair competition looks like saying
hey you want to win I have a challenge
and the challenge was whoever says you
want to have a challenge first wins yeah
exactly and he just they won by asking
the questions [ __ ] ridiculous
now you understand man Nick I'm really
competitive you challenge me I'm gonna
go yeah I'm gonna start my own app
called
with Ian yeah yeah I'll be so fun yeah
that's same exactly yeah we'll see into
you looks like that's gonna be awesome
but it's gonna be for only black people
it's gonna really work Blacks and Jews
because you know people always make fun
of Blacks and Jews but Blacks and Jews
will be the only ones who get to use my
app that's 75% of the ownership was land
really yeah and guys are way ahead of
the game but we're very diverse we have
like five different ethnicities and
singer
nothing is more diverse than Blacks and
Jews oh yeah me and Erin totally Erin
here another partner oh he's not here
I've never met him
can't just assume on the who Erin is by
mentioning you know read my dad every
day I don't operate and I read I read
could have been more interesting pelling
blog you nothing during the difference
leave that message at the log and you
can read all about us and our lifestyles
nothing like reading about how we read a
book yeah I did and all the information
you'd learn from that but that's what I
says like you know
brief history of time by Stephen Hawking
yeah Hunger Games Mockingjay part 2 like
to scan 3000 word review I breathe yeah
get the goods on Justin you're like this
guy leads a very normal what are you
doing weekend what I do on the weekends
crossword puzzles and drink I'm gonna do
lips I um
whoa that's a major assumption here
buddy I projecting this Linda I usually
wake up and then I add it ha film maybe
that's true you guys put out a lot of
content like SEO yeah and if no one's
here got some time to kill pornhub calm
maybe you corn sometimes xvideos redtube
is pretty good to butter some corn call
it a day yeah mmm those are porn sites
in case you guys didn't know the porn
sites I'm telling you I Nasir bait when
people are not here to destination